north has brought up several times now
that she wants a pet spider
and that is like absolutely never gonna
happen
kim kardashian is totally bugging over
her daughter north's
newest obsession get it bugging
anyway on keeping up with the
kardashians the kkw beauty founder
explains to her sister chloe
the seven-year-old totally has a thing
for
wait for it spiders
she's down for anything which just so
happens to be kim's absolute worst
freaking nightmare
somehow north conned me into going to
this pet store
that was right near her school and she
wants to see
the tarantulas and i go up to the lady
first i go listen i'll pay you a hundred
bucks just say they're
mean to kids not good pets they bite
everyone
say whatever you gotta say yeah i'll pay
you
yeah that didn't work because the pet
store employee totally did
the opposite the woman's like they make
great pets
do you want to hold it you know pulling
them out showing her and i'm literally
like
wait kim's face is a whole mood
let's run that back one more time
and just in case you didn't get the hint
kim doubled down and
spelled it out for us i have a pretty
awful relationship with spiders
i mean drink every time kim has had a
spider freak out on keeping up over the
years
oh my god shut up
[Music]
it's not real this time there's a spider
on you
no there's not more i feel like there's
a [ __ ] tarantula on my ass
[Music]
like this is my biggest nightmare i've
gotta get daddy
fat enough i don't wanna go on stairs
because i get big spider bites
no one with me and try to put one on me
or i'll literally
kill you yeah so you get the point i
literally just chugged wine
so what do you wanna do maybe i'll just
like i'll be sitting there and like
looking on my phone and i'll be like oh
my god did you hear the news
oh these kids died at a school from
tarantula bites
i'll just like [ __ ] out of them that's
not good
well that's one idea and while north
might not share her mom's fear of
spiders
kim told et she's actually a lot like
her and her famous dad kanye west
she's a gemini so she's a little bit of
both she definitely has kanye's outgoing
personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend
and then she's also really calm and
sweet like me sometimes
and she does share her mom's love of
makeup her
new favorite thing ever is no one in the
room no adults
closing the door with one of her friends
or her dolls and doing makeovers
and no one can see until the final look
is done or she'll
freak out and cry and you know oh north
loves a before and after
she loves it before and after but kim
told et
there's no pressure when it comes to
following in her parents
showbiz footsteps i hope that they
just find their own motivation and no
matter what that is no matter what they
want to do in life i hope that they work
really hard i think they have
good exam i i learned from seeing both
of my parents work really hard
and i think our kids will see you know
kanye and i work really hard
and i hope that's motivating for them
and just to find their own path i think
to not pressure but to definitely have
our rules
you